Shawn asks you are always answering
questions about business brands etc
what's the one life lesson you have
learned since becoming a father Shawn
this is a fun question for me I
appreciate it you know I I love this
show because I'm really shooting
straight and in me shooting straight
you're gonna almost really realize how
much of a contradiction I really am
you're gonna figure out how much of an
ego I actually have you're gonna figure
out how much humility I actually have
this is gonna go on the ego side
I've always been nurturing I love HR and
the team and like you guys the community
I have a lot of nurturing DNA you know
I'm a motherly kind of character I also
have an 11 year younger brother that
gave me a test run into fatherhood
because my brother and I have that kind
of relationship especially because my
dad is such a workaholic wasn't around
as much you know much more for AJ than
me I just want to throw that out there
did go to some of his basketball games
which I'm still jealous about and and in
general my dad's kind of an old-school
less nurturing let's put it that way
kind of guy and so you know when I'm 19
AJ is 8 what that did for me in a lot of
ways was you know it's not the same you
know brother even though as much as I
love AJ it's a different feeling from
children I think you know I think this
thing that it's taught me is the quote I
want to say unconditional love but the
truth is I probably love my parents and
siblings more than the average person
from what I've been able to gather and
so it's taught me things I knew which is
the fear that I have for any Missha
yesterday talking to me about you know
somebody called her chatterbox and I
hurt her feelings a made me laugh
because she's like her dad and I'm like
I remember going my music teacher in
first grade called me called me a
machine mouth or something like pretty
pretty tough anyway motormouth thank you
and so she's going through that stuff
and it was crazy to me to sit there and
feel how much pain and I felt and we're
not even in bullying zone or zit zone or
awkward teen yard zone so it's teaching
me that as much as I love my parents and
my siblings
and all these other things the love I
have for those two is is deep and it's
hardcore